[موسيقى]
في بعض كتير
مساجين يعني
اما انتحر نتيجه وصوله الى نقطه اسماء في
يستمر بالواقع اللي موجود فيه حاليا او
الجن يعني بيسموه فصل
فكان في نسبه معينه يعني داخل السجناء
حالتين اساسيتين
ممن ذكرتهما في ذكرتهما في الروايه حضرتك
فيما يتعلق بنسيم الذي ايضا يعني انتحر
لاحقا يعني بعد خروجه من السجن
والحاله الاخرى ايضا ممن جون لم يستطع
التحمل التحمل الواقع هذا الموجود وهذا
كان يحصل بسبب اساسي هو رؤيه ماسي الاخرين
مثل رجل كبير السن الذين اعدموا ثلاثه من
ابنائه الشباب
[موسيقى]
يعني صار نقاش طويل عريض بين
السجناء يعني بيني وبين رفقاتي داخل السجن
يعني يعني
وين بيكون شخص كتير مرهف الاحساس وكتير
رقيق وكثير حساس وشاعر وكذا وهذا ما قادر
يتحمل هذا الواقع
الاكثر ذكائنا ولا اكثر حساسيه والاكثر
رقه
بتحمل يعني بيتحمل ولكن يدخل الى عوالم
اخرى
الياس لا بد منه والقنوط منه
[موسيقى]